Yeah,
I'll delete.
Didn't hear a lot about Neal
Brennan special from people
that watch three months
while he was on there. That's
right. He was medians of the world.
Yeah.
Neil Brent Hill.
I want to say anything about his new
stuff because I'll give away the premises,
but he's murdered. He's super impressed
with Neal Brennan. I was like, Whoa,
this is the funniest I've ever heard
them. I love that. Oh, he's a monster.
He's very good. He's definitely the
best one I've seen so far on that,
on that species. He's very smart, man.
He's very smart and his
new stuff is excellent.
It's an analogy of Isis to talk,
don't say, but yeah. Yeah. Good.
He pushes up a lot of people.
Your favorite comedians. Shit.
He Punches Up Ellen's rock.
Chris Rock.
Dave Chappelle. He was Dave Chappelle's
writing part. I get, you know,
for the Chapelle show. Come on, was
back when we were friends with him.
He hadn't even done standup yet.
Remember that when we hung
out with them in New York,
Eddie came with me when I did, uh,
the fear factor, Chappelle sketch.
We did a weird ass warehouse.
How long ago was this?
2004. It was a long time ago. What's
it even, it might've been three.
Could have been three.
It was,
so we fly out to New York and they're
filming all day in this fucking old ass
warehouse with no windows and it's
freezing. Everybody's in winter coats.
And we had a like one
of those burner here,
things those portable like
inferno heater things.
Eddie and I were fucking huddled by
this time. Everybody was the camera man,
the grips. And um, he did,
um, the crackhead character,
Dave Chappelle stayed.
He stayed in character
the whole fucking day.
And he's trying to tell him about me.
Like he introduced me to Dave Chappelle.
He goes, this guy, he just tapped
toilet Gracie and he was like,
hi Gracie. Damn. Still
the whole bill all. Yeah.
So all, every time we ran into
each other throughout the day,
he'd look at me and
goes, you tap wise, crazy
ass over and over.
He would say the same shit.
I wonder why it took so Neil
so long to get into stand up.
He's such a brilliant room.
I think he sat back and watched it and
probably thought he could do it and then
said, no on, let me just give it a shot.
And he just took to it like
a duck to water. Yup. Yeah.